[Music]
foreign
[Music]
actually juggling the ball when I was
seven but at the age of 16 was the time
that I really started practicing
freestyle football
freestyle food for the West that's one
way for me to discover where my limits
were and to push my my boundaries to to
be a better not only a better athlete
but of course maybe just a better person
overall very having a lot of
perseverance and dedication discipline
that's something you can use not only in
sports but in life in your relationship
in work at work anything so I'm really
happy that I discovered somehow this
sport at a young age
foreign
really interesting that many stadiums if
not all have this sensorial room for
people with Attention Deficit Disorder
so that's great as a great Innovation I
hope many students in other places of
the world also adopt the same technology
when I was growing up I tried to like
unconsciously compare myself to other
other people instead of complaining
about my physical condition I started
being a positive person and for the last
I would say like 20 25 years it has been
my main motive of living like every day
waking up smiling and I try to inspire
more people to just keep this positive
our attitude not only for the self guard
just to expand the positiveness within
their their own Circle of Friends
[Music]
[Applause]